now those most interested in further
regulating and grabbing your guns are
constantly revealing how little they
actually know about Firearms now take
Rhode Island rep David siciline
but this
stabilizing brace which is depicted here
when when
attached here it turns this weapon into
an automatic weapon this bumps it
becomes a bump stock he just described
the arm brace which is used by people
who have a handicap to help fire a
pistol he just described it as a bump
stock
they have no idea what they're trying to
ban like if they could use Wikipedia
or a picture or something here really
quickly to understand that she what
she's offering has nothing to do with
the bump stock
joining me now is Congressman Tom Massey
the man you just saw explaining the
basics of a gun structure to that
Democratic representative congressman
have they figured out yet what they're
trying to ban other than saying weapons
of war which is a tedious phrase
they're they have such Zeal to ban
everything that they don't even know
what their bill bans and my colleague
rep Michelle fischbach she offered a
very simple amendment to say I just want
to make sure you're not Banning this
device that's used by disabled people to
fire a pistol and that's when they said
it was a machine gun look this is this
is a trend they we could laugh more at
their ignorance but here's the problem
Laura their ignorance causes them to
write bills that will cover law abiding
citizens they wrote A bill a couple
weeks ago and passed it to cover gun
traffickers but I pointed out to them it
would cover victims of domestic violence
if they merely borrowed a gun from their
neighbor in this same bill that they
passed
last week that sicilini was talking
about they're trying to ban bomb stocks
but they've written it in such a way
it'll cover a mechanism that lightens
the trigger pull like just makes your
gun easier to Fire and time and time
again they're over legislating I would
say because of their ignorance so I'm
torn do you educate them or do you just
let them flop around the problem is when
they flop around they ban everything
well tonight on NBC Merrick Garland the
Attorney General Congressman issued a
warning watch this
is a very cheap devices that can be made
at home that can transform
a semi-automatic rifle or a
semi-automatic pistol you just saw a
demonstration that's right for a few
cents a semi-automatic weapon became a
machine gun essentially exactly
your response they are they're coming
for the guns no doubt about it
well you saw there they're going to make
the argument that if a cheap thing can
you know convert a semi-automatic into a
fully automatic then they got to ban all
semi-automatics and that's what they
want to do they're calling these weapons
of war lore so I offered amendment that
said well let's make sure we don't give
weapons of war to the Department of
Education and to the USDA what possible
use could they have for those in their
missions and the Democrats argued that
the the Department of Education needs
what they're calling weapons of war of
course they're not weapons of war but
that's the way they want to you know
vilify common gun owners
well they think if they own the language
they'll own the argument right and so a
nine millimeter you're saying basically
a nine millimeter and a Glock 30 about
43 or 19 or 17. that ultimately is what
they want to ban right that's that's
ultimately where this is going
well you know Biden called it the lung
blower
the uh the two two three round is the
one that they're really vilifying now in
the House of Representatives but I
pointed out they're not Banning a 30-06
which is more than twice as powerful as
a two two three it's not about the
actual ballistics it's not about The
lethality of the gun it's just about how
it looks they want to ban a mini 14 in
one form but not ban it in another form
I had to show them in a picture they
were Banning and unbanning the same gun
the problem is you can't trust them you
can't trust their motives they hate the
Constitution Congressman thank you for
pointing this out you schooled Buddha
judge last week on the grid and Sicilian
this week hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else